petit très prétentieux non en tout cas
faire attention aux autres surtout quand
on sait ce qu'ils ont vécu ils ont vécu
des moments extrêmement traumatisant moi
je les ai pas vécu mais j'essaie d'être
le plus possible à leur écoute
ils n'ont pas besoin d'un technocrate
voilà qui vient leur donner des conseils
nous leur donner des instructions
voilà donc xavier pelletier très
apprécié par les élus même si on sait
bien que sa tâche est herculéenne lui le
problème c'est qu'ils doivent
reconstruire vite et en même temps pensé
le long terme ce qui semble on va dire à
ses antagonistes en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que la roya va mettre des
années à s'en remettre
philippe tabarot sur le sujet le sénat
veut aussi avoir son mot à dire son
impulsion à donner et notamment
peut-être dans le cadre de futurs
projets de loi climat 4d vous avez
peut-être nous le préciser mais vous
vous voulez notamment assouplir la loi
montagne à ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce que vous pouvez faire alors
parce qu'il faut rappeler ces cas ce
préfet c'est l'image de l'état qu'on
aime que l'état soit incarné
physiquement par quelqu'un qui essaie de
régler les problèmes et pas vous mettre
des bâtons dans les roues comme ça c'est
une première chose
et deuxièmement les fonds dont vous avez
parlé d'état les millions qu'a prévu le
président macro ne sont pas encore
arrivées et troisième point il faut
qu'on arrive dans cette maison notamment
faire évoluer la législation la loi
montagne
la sénatrice dominique estrosi sassone a
déposé une ppl que nous avons soutenu
pour permettre tout simplement ne pas
faire de spéculations foncières ou mais
mais mais de permettre de reconstruire
ses instincts équipements publics
certaines maisons mais simplement un
assouplissement dans l'interprétation de
cette loi pourrait permettre de
reconstruire un certain nombre de
maisons et pour garder de la vie et de
faire re
les habitants dans cette vallée de la
roya et merci beaucoup je vous invite à
suivre à 22h ce soir ce reportage royat
au chevet d'une vallée où jonathan vous
a donc suivi et on signale que nos
partenaires de nice matin font toute la
semaine des reportages dans ces vallées
pour savoir où en est la reconstruction
merci beaucoup merci jonathan merci
beaucoup
philippe tabarot merci d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin vous allez laisser votre
place à patrick kanner qui est le
président du groupe socialiste
ici au sénat et qui va s'installer
à vue voilà on est en direct merci
beaucoup
philippe tabarot et bonjour patrick
kanner bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce matin on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes on va vous mettre un
micro quand même parce que ça va être
beaucoup plus et bomba super tout est
parfait équipez vous êtes équipé ses
supers donc sénateur du nord président
de socialistes écologistes et
républicains et comme tous les jours
cette interview et en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale dont
l'or fait qu'on puisse en jeu rien merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous journalistes à
la république du centre patrick kanner
on commence évidemment par la crise
sanitaire et le conseil scientifique qui
a donc rendu son avis hier alors iront
son avis mais ils tranchent pas vraiment
une décision sur le report des
régionales et départementales
est ce que vous dites qu'il a eu raison
de laisser l'exécutif tranché oui
évidemment
évidemment lors donc j'ai eu accès à ce
rapport voilà il est là je le montre à
nos téléspectateurs donc c'est un
rapport très circonstancié qui fait ce
qu'on appelle dans notre jargon du
benchmarking il regarde un peu ce qui
s'est passé aussi à l'étranger beaucoup
de pays ont voté pendant cette période
de crise épidémique donc le conseil
scientifique dit qu'il conte doit voter
qu'on peut voter mais il fait des
préconisations
tout en laissant bien sûr le politique
faire son choix final je pense que nous
aurons sûrement une réunion très
prochaine avec mathieu castex pour
examiner le contenu de ce rapport mais
qui n'est qui est fixée ont pas encore
pas encore mais je pense que ça va
tomber aujourd'hui au niveau de la date
en tout cas est la principale
préconisation du conseil scientifique
entre les vignes quoique c'est même
presque direct ses désirs on sera mieux
en septembre on sera mieux en septembre
40 45 millions de vaccinés beaucoup de
personnes qui ont fait aussi à kovy donc
finalement immunité collective potentiel
fin septembre début octobre
et on sent bien qu'elle ait la tendance
qui serait souhaitée par le conseil
scientifique tout en rejetant très
réservé parce qu'elle dit qu'on sera
mieux sur le sur le plan du vaccin mais
qu'il n'exclut pas une reprise de noix
la paix mis un éventuellement de
nouveaux variants qui pourrait
l'emporter sur les vacciner
d'aujourd'hui vous voyez quand même
qu'il ya beaucoup d'incertitude et dans
ce cadre là il vaudrait mieux faire les
élections au mois de juin alors contre
la lecture de cet avis quelle va être
votre position du coup à bâtonnets nous
avons une réunion avec olivier faur
notre premier secrétaire à 9h30 par
visio on va travailler ensemble sur les
hypothèses mais encore une fois il y a
le gouvernement il ya l'opposition et le
gouvernement doit prendre ses
responsabiltés scission personnel
monsieur k nerfs sur la question à ma
position à sept jours de le dire il faut
de maintenir les élections parce que je
ne sais pas ce qui se passera en
septembre
très simplement mais par contre et là le
conseil scientifique nous donne raison à
nous socialistes qui avons porté
plusieurs propositions vote par
correspondance la distance vote aussi
par anticipation
tout est dit le conseil dit mais on
aurait pu on aurait dû améliorer le
processus électoral
améliorer le code des élections pour
faciliter l'élection et temps la
majorité de droite ici au sénat que le
gouvernement nous a écarté d'un revers
de manche toutes ces propositions
je le regrette parce que finalement si
on vous avez écouté il ya plus d'un an
que nous évoquons ses solutions
potentielles qui ne sont que technique
mais qui favorise le process électorale
si on nous avait écoutés peut-être que
le concession des filles qui aurait dit
bravo c'est bien c'est ce qu'il fallait
faire
hélas il n'en est qu'aux recommandations
alors que nous nous avait fait ses
propositions
oui le conseil scientifique qui est
prêtre et s'ils regrettent que la
digitalisation des votes elle votes par
correspondance ne puisse être envisagée
pour ces élections c'est bon pour que
les traits qu'on avait fait opposition
manière systématique à chaque occasion
potentiel ici au sénat un mot sur le pic
de la deuxième vague qui est désormais
atteint voire dépassé en tout cas pour
le nombre de réanimation le nombre de
dons de réanimation est aujourd'hui plus
importante que lors de la deuxième vague
est ce qu'on peut encore attendre pour
confiner le pays patrie cana moi je me
reporte au conseil
enfin à la réunion parlementaire le
comité parlementaire de liaison du 28
janvier
j'ai retrouvé mes notes est toujours bon
de 35
et j'avais écouté messieurs castex avec
beaucoup d'attention et à l'époque ce
casse tête disait le gouvernement doit
prendre les décisions qui relèvent de sa
responsabilité il ya une dégradation des
chiffres spitalier le variant est
manifestement très grave
monsieur castex révérend le 28 janvier
dise clairement combat tout droit vers
une très grosse difficultés sanitaires
qui divergent selon vous entre le
premier c'est son ministre de la santé
et le président de la république c'est
évident parce que comme le dit très bien
notre collègue bernard jomier dans un
grand hebdomadaire
il ya quelques jours le président de la
république il n'a pas eu de manque
d'anticipation il savait les chiffres et
dans le marbre
à l'époque nous avions 10 % de variants
anglais 10% à l'époque aujourd'hui nous
sommes entre 70 et 80 voire plus pour
cent dans les départements français
donc on savait au travers des
algorithmes de ce variant parce qu'on
avait l'expérience chez nos amis anglais
on savait parfaitement quelles seraient
les courbes mi mars fin mars début avril
et nous y sommes exactement nous y
sommes ce qui veut dire que le choix du
présent la république a été un choix
totalement assumé
certains peuvent dire pour des raisons
économiques
probablement mais aussi pour des raisons
d'acceptabilité des français face à un
nouvel endroit qu'il aurait fallu ont
confiné plus je suis en traitement
mais moi je les on dit souvent les
politiques n'ont rien dit à l'époque
excusez moi moi j'ai tweeté le 29
janvier pouvez le retrouver sur le thème
ces mesures sont insuffisantes on va
dans le mur en klaxonnant n'a pas
apprécié ce que j'ai dit et monsieur
macron va parler dans quelques jours
finalement il
il n'a pas parlé il a il a pris une
décision il a laissé faire et là vous
lui demander de parler rapidement à moi
je lui demande de parler alors on me dit
qu'il ne parlerait plus mercredi comme
c'était annoncé peut-être que ça va
venir
bon enfin mais vous le dites il doit
parler dès demain il doit assumer les
décisions qu'il a prises dès demain dès
demain dès que possible des possibles
quand les chiffres seront assumés là
aussi parce que finalement le président
le maître du temps a été dans cette
affaire le maître du temps me gibert te
ment ballon vous reparler de de pouvoir
solitaire je cite nous sommes devant un
pouvoir solitaire qui peut devenir
mortifère et vous déclarez et quelques
jours au sujet d' emmanuel macron c'est
une déclaration forte pour vous
l'arrogance supposées du chef de l'état
lui ferait manqué de clairvoyance c'est
ça mais même accro ne doute pas il pense
que ses choix sont les meilleurs qu'il
est le champion de l'épidémiologie
mondiale est ce que d'ailleurs je
ferrand qui me donne un brevet de
satisfaction en matière scientifique
n'est pas scientifique monsieur macron
il n'a pas écouté les recommandations du
conseil scientifique d'ailleurs il
écoute de moins en moins mais c'est quoi
c'est son tempérament c'est ça son
exercice du pouvoir
vous avez été ministre à lui si je vois
que son mode de gestion peut être très
différent de notre grand voisin allemand
madame merkel consultant permanence je
dirais même qu'elle co construit en
permanence les solutions pas toujours
facile mais elle co construit le modèle
n'est pas le même en allemagne évident
certes mais je pense que la personnalité
n'est pas la même non plus et que
manifestement mais les échéances
électorales ne sont pas les mêmes non
plus ouais mais monsieur macro
aujourd'hui dans son conseil de défense
bouquet risée et qui est ballotté au fil
des
des événements monsieur macron décide
seul qui l'écoutent que lui-même je
pense qu'ils écoutent il décide seul un
monde les la vraie question c'est est-ce
que sur un sujet comme celui là notre
sport collectif
notre sort individuel peut dépendre d'un
seul homme c'est une vraie question
figurent la gestion du pouvoir en
général à travers cette crise c'est quel
rapport entre le président de la
république élu au suffrage universel
direct dans la vème république et le
reste de la population le reste des élus
nous en tant que parlementaire nous ne
sommes que vous demandez un débat au
parlement mais ça fait des mois que nous
demandons à des mains dans le cas de
l'artiste 50-1 la constitution nous
voulons un débat on va avoir des bas
bientôt parce qu'il va voir la loi de
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
l'état d'urgence s'arrête le 1er juin
nous allons avoir une loi dont on
gassion à moins que le il ya un miracle
sanitaire je ne crois pas
malheureusement donc bis mais on va voir
cette loterie ovation et bien ce sera la
première fois mi mai depuis le mois de
décembre que nous aurons un débat
politique de fond sur cette crise
sanitaire du troc c'est normal
la réponse est non à un mot sur la
question des écoles qui inquiète
évidemment qui est importante est ce que
vous dites qu'il faut fermer les écoles
dès maintenant
moi je pense qu'il faut profiter des
vacances qui arrivent pour au moins
accordé une semaine de peluches de
vacances mais des vacances qui arrivent
en respectant les vacances des zones ou
en avançant les vacances dans certaines
zones
écoutez il ya des zones où il ya trois
zones il faut respecter les zones mais
il faut profiter de cette période en
l'expliquant aux parents je sais que
c'est compliqué parce qu'il faut prévoir
des moyens de garde mais on aurait pu le
faire déjà des mois février
on l'a refusé et ont dit nous étions
beaucoup à le demander de droite et de
gauche ça a été refusé
là devant l'urgence on a un bon moyen
d'éviter que les clusters dans les
écoles se développe c'est effectivement
augmenté à l'est d'une semaine c'est
quand même pas dramatique
le temps des vacances scolaires c'est
d'une semaine dans chaque zone
voilà par exemple et je crois que là ça
permettrait d'avoir un étalement plus
important du des vacances et donc
potentiellement de mieux freiner le
virus si l'on sait qu'il se développe
malheureusement avec le mariage anglais
très souvent chez les jeunes on va
passer à l'autre actualité l'autre
actualité au sénat c'est la loi
séparatisme les sénateurs vont commencer
à l'examiner cet après midi vous vous y
êtes opposés à cette loi c'est un
euphémisme vous allez nous en parler est
ce que vous êtes sûr de voter contre ou
est-ce que la teneur des débats peuvent
vous faire changer d'avis heureusement
que l'on peut changer d'avis en cours de
débat nous allons présenter à peu près
70 80 amendement du groupe socialiste
pour améliorer le texte comme nous le
faisons bien sûr systématiquement
amendements sur quoi amendements sur par
exemple le le fait que quand on est élu
on doit respecter plus que jamais les
principes de la république des choses
comme cela donc très honnêtement les
amendements 6 à caractère social puisque
ce sera l'occasion d'une question
préalable que je vais poser au
gouvernement tout à l'heure pour dire la
dimension lutte contre les inégalités
sociales qui est essentiel qui est
derrière
y compris reconnu par le milieu de
l'intérieur lui-même n'est pas n'est pas
dans ce texte
donc ce texte déséquilibré les
intentions on peut les comprendre on
peut les diagnostics et favorablement
bien évidemment il faut lutter contre
l'islam politique et toutes formes de
séparatisme dans notre pays simplement
on voit bien que on ne se disent pas
déjà les lois qui existent premièrement
et deuxièmement manifestement
manifestement il y a une volonté
surenchère de la part du gouvernement
surenchère qui sera surenchérit
permettez-moi la redondance par la
droite sénatoriale donc à votre question
initiale va-t-on de voter pour ou contre
je crains que la droite sénatoriale
notamment sur la question du voile dans
le domaine public va vouloir en faire
plus vouloir dramatiser les choses dans
une concurrence interne d'ailleurs à la
droite depuis les déclarations de xavier
bertrand qui rend finalement non
bruno retailleau oui bien sûr nous avons
plus de candidats à droite monsieur
bertrand s'est déclaré monsieur
retailleau va sûrement un jour se
déclarer et c'est donc cette surenchère
pour aller sanaa colisée davantage le
débat c'est ce que vous dites à vos jeux
wii jeu j'en suis intimement convaincu
ce qui est dommage parce que sur un
thème comme cela on devrait avoir un
consensus républicain
aucune mesure dans ce texte qui grâce à
vos yeux
je vais je vais le dire sera mis sur les
droits des familles les choses
intéressantes sur la transparence pour
le financement des cultes et des choses
intéressantes mais le péché originel
permettez moi l'expression consacrée en
l'occurrence péché originel c'est que on
fait un diagnostic sur l'islam radical
qui existe s'il y a aujourd'hui des
prédateurs c'est qu'il ya des proies
potentielles et on n'en existe pas
pourquoi il ya des proies
il ya des proies parce que la république
ne rentre pas dans certains quartiers
aujourd'hui on l'a toujours sur l'a
toujours dit c'est toute la politique de
la ville qui aujourd'hui n'existe
quasiment plus dans notre dans notre
pays donc il faut le dire il faut
dénoncer ces dérives
en tant que tel mais il faut s'attaquer
aux causes et on al'impression qu'avec
cette fois on va peut-être casser le
thermomètre mais ce n'est pas en cassant
terme être que la fièvre va
automatiquement comment supporter la
république revienne dans ces quartiers
abbès est pas moins au mieux d'état
c'est plus d'état c'est plus d'état il
faut réarmer ses quartiers en service
public en présence associative et
secteur associatif a été saccagée mais
en tout cas extrêmement affaibli
extrêmement affaibli depuis le début du
quinquennat par la perte des contrats
aidés il faut réinventer la notion
d'éducation populaire qui vous paraître
un peu ringarde sa dette de 36 1936
l'éducation populaire
mais si vous avez le sentiment qu'ils
avaient plus d'état dans ces quartiers
de au cours du mandat de françois ozon
assez sais j'aurais aimé moi extremis de
la ville j'aurais aimé qu'on ait encore
plus de moyens mais là j'ai le sentiment
que on a fait vraiment un voire deux
voire trois pas en arrière on a continué
les mesures de rénovation urbaine mais
tout ce qui est le tissu social le tissu
associatif
le service public on n'y a pas vraiment
mis les moyens je le regrette c'est ce
qu'on nous dirons tout au long de ce
débat
oui il faut lutter contre l'islam
politique on est tous d'accord
naturellement sur le sujet mais en plus
il faut que cette république forte que
nous aspirons à laquelle nous aspirons
aussi naturellement sous
bienveillante et donc qu'elle puisse
apporter ce qui fait la promesse
républicaine permettre à chaque jeune
dans ces quartiers de considérer que le
dit d'un côté et le prêche d'un imam
islamiste de l'autre ne constitue pas
finalement la seule voie possible pour
un jeune dans une société telle que la
nôtre
un mot sur puisque un domaine que vous
connaissez bien c'est le sport par
exemple le sénat veut renforcer la lutte
contre les certificats de complaisance
dans ce texte qui permette de sousse
tard par exemple les jeunes filles à la
piscine est ce que là vous êtes
favorable oui bien sûr bien sûr encore
une fois qui ait pas de malentendu nous
ne sommes pas laxistes avec les schèmes
politique et je pense que le quinquennat
précédent que vous évoquez la montre et
moment notamment des attentats
on ne peut pas dire que monsieur bernard
cazeneuve a été laxiste pendant cette
période que le moins qu'on puisse dire
à partir de là tout ce qui va dans le
bon sens nous le soutiendrons simplement
nous encore une fois nous référençons
manque d' équilibre entre le constat la
réponse autoritaire la réponse
régaliennes qui est nécessaire et la
réponse sociale finalement monsieur
macron 10 qui les unit le droite ni de
gauche
il s'appuie quand même essentiellement
aujourd'hui sur sa jambe de droite il
veut donner des gages il veut donner des
gages à la droite y compris sénatoriales
et on l'a vu d'ailleurs hier soir dans
la cadre de la commission mixte
paritaire est justement leur sécurité
globale on va bien que le la semaine
nationale beaucoup lâché au sénat
pour ajouter à la hausse en ciel il ya
eu un accord pour préciser entre les
députés et sénateurs hier sur cette
proposition de la sécurité globale et
effectivement il ya près 80 % des
apports du sénat qui ont été repris dans
sa réinscription de l'article 24
est ce que vous dites mais c'est quand
même une victoire politique du sénat
c'est quand même la victoire du belize
et surtout c'est surtout
un geste envoyé par monsieur macro et
les siens majorité aasm nationale aux
sénateurs de droite du sénat on voit
bien quand même que derrière ça il ya
des préoccupations tactique parce que ce
texte
aujourd'hui considèrent que la police
nationale peut de plus en plus s'appuyer
sur d'autres solutions pour porter la
réponse de l'état police municipale
police de sécurité privée aura police la
sécurité privée de l'autre nous on n'y
est pas favorable
on veut que la police nationale prenne
toute sa place dans les territoires donc
tout ceci a été effectivement lâché
entre guillemets au sénat victoire du
piquet meriem surtout opération tactique
encore une fois de la majorité de l'anc
il me vient de l'annoncer canard à
badens d'élargir à droite d'élargir à
d'autres préparent déjà 2022 parce bien
celle de 2022 c'est dans un an
aujourd'hui la france en pleine campagne
à l'époque dont si tout va bien deux je
pense que là ça devrait aller tout cas
je croise les doigts comme vous pour y
parvenir et donc chez makro et déjà dans
une stratégie d'élargissement de sa
majorité à droite il sait que la la
gauche est fini il a fait une croix sur
l'électorat de gauche et ses
représentants il sait que c'est fini
j'ai pour vous la gauche et non non il
sait que le soutien de la gauche qu'il
avait eue en 2017 n'existe plus pour lui
ait pas de malentendu donc c'est à nous
de savoir remplir l'espace qu'il laisse
libre électeurs de gauche ne se
retournera un nouveau venu au sein du
passage je ne suis pas madame irma je
n'ai pas une boule de cristal je dis
simplement que aujourd'hui si nous
sommes capables d'apporter une réponse
et une incarnation au moment des
élections présidentielles et bien
monsieur macron devra se reposer
essentiellement sur l'électorat de
droite et donc sa surface diminuer parce
qu'il sera pris entre d'un côté madame
le pen d'un côté un candidat de droite
éventuel donc son intérêt aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment d'élargir sa surface et
notamment à droite et on va justement
parlé des élections va parler des
régionales un flan oui absolument seul
avant la présidentielle il ya les
élections régionales on ne sait pas
encore évidemment à quelle date 1 en
ile-de-france audrey pulvar
la candidate soutenue par votre parti a
créé la polémique ce week-end en se
déclarant favorable aux réunions non
mixtes raciale avec la possibilité
offerte aux blancs je cite d'y assister
mais uniquement s'ils se taisent quelle
est votre position sur ce sujet brûlant
mais ce qui est bien c'est évident que
je ne peux pas partager cette position
je le dis et je connais l'engagement
madame pulvar pour lutter contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme les formes de
discrimination à l'égard des femmes
enfin julich qui ait pas de malentendu
audrey pulvar n'est pas entre guillemets
un relais de l'unef et des dérives que
nous avons pu compter de l'unef
mais je n'aurais pas dit les choses la
manière je pense qu'il peut y avoir des
groupes de parole pour que des personnes
qui se sentent agressés puisse parler
entre elles mais je crois à
l'universalisme
je crois à la réponse la plus large
possible je pense que ces personnes qui
sont discriminés ne sont pas les seuls à
pouvoir lutter contre leur propre
discriminations qu'elles subissent comme
une faute politique audrey pulvar une
faute morale c'est c'est une phrase on
aurait pu éviter
voilà mais la campagne va continuer je
lui apporte tout mon soutien je connais
c'est encore être la candidate et se
jure bien sûr il faut voilà il faut que
faut assumer
voilà vous savez dans une campagne
électorale il peut y avoir un mot de
trop ou compris sur un plateau un comme
comme ici pas un mot qui peut coûter on
se souvient de claude bartolone a jusque
là aussi vous dites il peut se
reproduire ça gèle à la campagne va
durer au minimum jusqu'au 13 juin
peut-être plus plus tard donc il faudra
sûrement qu'ils explications pour vous
c'est le foot de parcours mais ça veut
dire c'est une faute de carre comme on
dit quand on fait du ski c'est une faute
de carre en tout cas pour moi après mais
ça veut dire qu'elle doit s'expliquer
pour vous vous dites il faut que je
pense qu'à elle de qu'elle doit
s'expliquer qu'elle doit rassurer et
qu'elle doit pas laisser entendre que
quelque part l oreille
démarche rachis j'ai une démarche
d'essence désocialisation des personnes
le racisme existe dans notre pays
s'expliquer devant les socialistes
notamment elle n'est pas socialiste
elle n'est pas socialiste mais les
circuits papa de chaalis et donc oui il
est évident que dans le cadre de cette
faute de cas comme comme je les appelais
eh bien il faut que même pulvar puisse
se dire ce qu'elle pensait réellement
une interview encore une fois il peut y
avoir une parole de tron paroles
maladroites
moi j'étais à assumer derrière c'est pas
là jamais dit que c'était un propos
maladroite sa part oui mais je vous dis
vous me demander à moi les gens pensent
je vous réponds que je n'aurais pas tenu
ces propos là ce n'est pas ma conception
de la lutte contre le racisme de la
lutte contre les discriminations jeu
encore une fois je crois aux réponses
universaliste en tant que socialiste est
ce que c'est un sujet embarrassant pour
le parti socialiste tient plus non
errants depuis ce week-end quand même
nos s'est passé pas enfin lequel sujet
le les propos qu'a tenus en mai bien
qu'on en parle
la preuve oui mais je ne refuse pas de
d'en parler je dis simplement que ce
n'est pas la position du parti
socialiste et que quand vous lisez
monsieur olivier faure sur notamment les
dérives de l'unef je crois qu'il a
montée très clair quand le parti
socialiste ne ne va pas sur la marche
contre du mystérieux phobie nous sommes
très clairs et sur la laïcité nous
n'avons pas de leçons à recevoir de
personne et on va parler fait régir les
autres ans
oui absolument le président sortant la
région des hauts de france xavier
bertrand est également candidat donc à
la fois pour sa succession régionale et
à la présidentielle ne craignez-vous pas
que ça solar is le débat dans cette
région et surtout que ça le nationalise
au détriment finalement des enjeux
régionaux
c'est un choix là aussi très assurée par
monsieur
bertand il j'ai pu le dire il a sûrement
le don d'ubiquité
c'est bien c'est bien en politique
d'avoir autant de force
je le dis qu'on ne voyait pas sourire
mais je me souviens on compte en jeu
quand je dis ça de ville où le deviner
bon non je pense que les six millions de
nordistes qui subissent aujourd'hui de
plein front la crise sanitaire qui ont
une espérance de vie moindre qu'ailleurs
qui ont des problèmes de santé mérite un
président à plein temps et pour être
présent à plein temps il faut un
candidat à plein temps et donc je me
demande si finalement monsieur bertrand
n'utilise pas cette élection régionale
comme simplement un faire-valoir de sa
campagne présidentielle
un mélange des genres d'ailleurs qui est
critiquable sur le plan est ce que
politicien jury champlain juridique si
vous voulez manger bien l'étoile est
content de l'accord les comptes de
campagne sont décalés pour l'élection
présidentielle mais néanmoins tout ceci
se mélange de manière curieuse mais
voilà dont acte pour l'instant il n'y a
pas eu de dépenses de monsieur bertrand
en matière plus loin on ira on regardera
parce que si monsieur bertrand se
déplace dans le cas de sa campagne
présidentielle
ailleurs que dans la région il faudra
que bien sûr les choses soient claires
mais je lui fais confiance pour ne pas
empiéter sur les lois existantes en tout
cas ne pas les laits déformé par contre
comment peut-on être sérieusement
candidat à une élection aussi importante
que les élections régionales c'est pas
une élection d'un village isolé c'est
une élection régionale de six millions
d'habitants et être candidat aux
élections présidentielles je ne vois pas
comment c'est possible ça va dire que
monsieur bertrand a déjà son successeur
en tête et j'ai déjà un mois un nom dans
ce cas là qu'il le dise ce qu'il devait
jalili a nom et qui circulent
vous le dire je vais pas vous le dire
parce que voilà ce n'est pas officiel et
lui doit le dîner mais en tout cas il ne
doit pas prendre en otage les nordistes
si les candidats aux régionales il faut
dire mais oui je suis candidat aux
régionales mais je ne serai pas votre
président parce que j'irai au combat
parce que là c'est pas honnête
la glace est assez
[Musique]